Q Anon friendly radical trumpian
republican congresswoman Marjorie Taylor
green
said she doesn't believe in evolution
during a bonker's off-the-wall interview
with Steve Bannon on his so-called War
Room program now I want to be really
clear here if you want to Simply see
this as it's just another nutty thing
Marjorie Taylor green said and leave it
at that you can do that but understand
that the world sees what I am about to
play for you and the world is shocked
the Civilized World anyway how does the
United States still have people in the
House and Senate forget about people who
deny climate change that ship has sailed
but we still have people in the House
and Senate who deny Evolution and I want
to get into a little bit later the
terminology of don't believe in
evolution we're going to get to that
because that's a problem too the context
was apparently coveted 19 and the lab
leak Theory and it caused Marjorie
Taylor green to casually drop in that
she doesn't believe in evolution Okay
let's listen you hang on you don't buy
that you don't buy the argument that say
Hey the gain of function is all because
we've got to take these viruses and
we've got to power them up to look for
vaccines and to look for other Solutions
in case somehow they they come up with
this you don't buy you don't buy the
logic of that is that what you're saying
no I don't buy it because I don't
believe in evolution I don't believe in
in that type of so-called science I
don't believe in evolution I believe in
God and there's these viruses we're not
making people sick until they created
them and made them and to weaponize
these viruses to be able to attach to to
our cells and make us sick this has
caused so many people to die all over
the world this is a bio weapon all right
so the terminology she doesn't believe
in evolution so the virus couldn't have
evolved but she believes in God but then
says the virus was created by them
meaning China but how could China create
anything if everything is God's creation
that's crazy and coherent I don't even
want to focus about that I focus on that
today that's not that's crazy but I
don't want to focus on that
this is an outrageous rant and it's an
ignorant screed but understand that this
is a member of the United States
Congress voted in by her constituents in
the state of Georgia when I first saw
this story I scrolled by and I thought
it said oh Marjorie Taylor green says
she doesn't believe in education that's
not actually the headline but it might
as well be so let's talk about belief in
evolution I hate it when people say this
maybe it's you don't accept evolution
it might more accurately be you don't
understand Evolution but don't believe
in evolution it seems it makes it seem
as though it's an issue of Faith imagine
if someone didn't believe in gravity we
say well what difference does it make
you have no choice but to accept it and
to exist in a physical world in which
gravity is a reality you might not
understand it but to not believe in
gravity sounds as idiotic as you imagine
it to be and so when people say I don't
believe in evolution it should really be
thought of in the exact same way it
should sound just as strange to us she
doesn't understand it she apparently
wants to keep other people from
understanding it but the main point here
is if I said I don't believe the sun is
the source of heat on the surface of the
Earth
I might not accept it I might not
understand it but the reason I can go
outside and it's a temperature that is
suitable for human life is that it is
the reality it doesn't matter whether I
understand it or accept it or believe in
it it's really dumb to say I don't
believe the sun heats up the Earth and
it's really dumb to say I don't believe
in evolution people who say it should be
seen the same way as people who say I
don't believe in gravity I don't believe
the sun heats the Earth these views
should be ostracized and they should be
called out but the most important part
is this should disqualify you from from
being an elected official if you don't
accept or understand or believe in to
use their term something this
uncontroversial how can you be trusted
to do anything about any issue ever now
one funny thing
if anything were to make me question
Evolution it would sort of be Marjorie
Taylor green what I mean by that is life
has evolved for millions and millions of
years we come out of the ocean and down
from the trees and we develop medicine
and Science and Netflix and technology
and air travel and yet somehow Marjorie
Taylor green still exists I'm kidding
I'm kidding but I'm also sort of not if
you understand what I'm saying
horrifying that this is what we have we
have 435 members of Congress
and she doesn't understand or accept
evolution to use her word she doesn't
believe in it it's a global humiliation
my friends and it must be changed
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely free
service at privacy.com Pacman I've been
using privacy for a little over a year
now you've heard me talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone instead of actually using your
real credit card number the privacy app
and the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even auto fill the card number
with one click and the payment is taken
out of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them anytime you want so when you
do this it means you're not going to be
charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling
companies who you are you're keeping
your bank or credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free and like I said you'll get
five dollars to spend when you sign up
at privacy.com Pacman